RESPOND.
THEY SEEM TO HAVE WENT DARK.
IF THEY DON'T RESPOND THEY'LL
GET A TO APPEAR BEFORE CONGRESS
AND TREATED WITH A DEPOSITION.
>> FINDING OUT WHAT THE OBAMA
OFFICIALS KNEW.
FOX NEWS LEGAL ANALYST, THE
FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE,
SPEED ON FOR A YEAR.
NO DOSSIER.
I'M SORRY.
NO DOSSIER, NO APPLICATION TO
SPY ON YOU AND PROVE YOU THE
ENTIRE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> GREAT TO BE IN THE MIDDLE.
ISN'T IT?
>> COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL.
>> MUELLER, YOU'RE ON THE LIST
OF PEOPLE THAT HE'S ASKING FOR
THE E-MAILS AND TEXTS.
DO YOU KNOW WHO THE INDIVIDUAL
IS THAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT?
>> THIS IS --
>> IS IT GUY MELTING DOWN ON TV
TONIGHT?
>> THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING.
AFTER EVERYTHING, THIS IS A
SMALL DROP IN THE BUCKET.
KIND OF -- BECOME PRETTY NUMB A
LONG TIME AGO.
>> WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THE
LIST?
WHAT IS FASCINATING IS I HAVE MY
LIST OF PEOPLE THAT NEED IT
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
>> FIRST THING YOU DO IS TO
BEGIN SUBPOENAING ALL OF THE
DOCUMENTS OF TEXTS AND E-MAILS
AND OTHER COMMUNICATIONS.
HERE WE ARE TEN MONTHS LATER AND
YOU KNOW, MUELLER IS KIND OF
GETTING AROUND TO DOING THAT
>> A LITTLE LATE.
>> YEAH.
>> FOR THIS GUY SHANDONBURG WHO
IS A PERIPHERAL FIGURE BEFORE HE
GOT FIRED FROM THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN HAS BEEN HAUL ALONG IN
AN INCREDIBLY ERRATIC MELTDOWN
WAY AND MAKING BASELESS
ACCUSATIONS THAT HE HAD NO
ACCESS TO.
HE SAID OF CARTER PAGE, HE SAID
CARTER COLLUDED WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
HE NEVER EVEN MET WITH NUNBERG.
>> ON FAKE NEWS EARLIER ON.
I THINK MY NAME CAME UP AND FREE
AIR TIME AND PROMOTION.
AND THEY'RE OBSESSED WITH US.
LET'S WATCH.
>> SO SAM, I HAVE TO ASK YOU
ONE OTHER THING.
IT IS AN AWKWARD QUESTION TO
ASK.
YOU'RE SITTING CLOSE TO ME.
WE TALKED EARLIER ABOUT WHAT?
PEOPLE IN THE WHITE HOUSE, YOU
WERE DRINKING ON DRUGS OR
WHATEVER HAPPENED TODAY.
TALKING TO YOU, I HAVE SMELLED
ALCOHOL ON YOUR BREATH.
>> I HAVE NOT HAD A DRINK.
>> YOU HAVEN'T HAD A DRINK.
>> NO.
>> SO I JUST BECAUSE IT IS THE
TALK OUT THIS.
I KNOW IT IS AWKWARD.
GIVE YOU THE QUESTION.
>> MY ANSWER IS NO.
>> LET'S GO AFTER THE GUY THAT
APPEARS TO BE HAVING A NATIONAL
MELTDOWN AND SMELL BOOZE ON YOUR
BREATH, NOT ME.
>> THERE'S PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN INTOXICATED FOR OVER A YEAR
AND A HALF NOW.
NOTHING NEW HERE.
HOW LU
HOW L
HOW AR
HOW ARE
HOW ARE YO
HOW ARE YOU
HOW ARE YOU G
HOW ARE YOU GOI
HOW ARE YOU GOING
HOW ARE YOU GOING T
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO R
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO RESPO
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO RESPOND
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO RESPOND T
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO RESPOND TO
MUELLER?
>> I'M COOPERATIVE WITH ANYONE
THAT WANTS TO TALK TO ME.
THE MORE THE TRUTH GETS OUT THE
BETTER.
>> ANYTHING YOU HEAR THAT
RESONATES AS TRUTH?
>> I WAS CALLED BY REPORTERS.
THEY ASKED FOR A REACTION.
ASK HIM WHERE THE FACTS ARE.
EVERYTHING SHOULD BE BASED ON
FACTS.
UNFORTUNATELY IT HAS BEEN PRETTY
SELDOM FOCUSED ON THAT THUS FAR.
>> NOW WE TALK ABOUT
INVESTIGATIVE CREED WE'RE
LOOKING INTO THE EMIRATES AND
WE'RE LOOKING INTO NUNBERG AND
WHAT THEY KNOW ABOUT HIM.
I'M JUST -- WHERE IS THE TRUMP
RUSSIA COLLUSION BECAUSE EVEN ON
THE VIEW, MR. TV HIMSELF SHIFT
SAID THERE'S NOTHING.
HE COULDN'T NAME ANY EVIDENCE.
>> HE FINALLY IS BACK TRACKING.
HE WAS THE DRIVING FORCE IN
EVERY TELEVISION SHOW HE COULD
GET ON THAT SAID TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION WOULD PROVE IT.
THERE'S COMPELLING EVIDENCE HE
SAID.
NOW HE DOESN'T HAVE A SHRED OF
EVIDENCE.
THREE COMMITTEES INVESTIGATED
FOR A YEAR AND A HALF.
NOT A BIT OF EVIDENCE.
IT IS ABOUT TIME HE WRAPPED THIS
UP.
>> HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE YOU
GOING TO SUE?
>> YOU KNOW, MY -- MY MAIN
FOCUS NOW IS ON THE DEFAMATION
FRONT.
THAT'S MOVING ALONG.
IT IS SIMILAR TO FISA WHERE
THEY'RE OVERLOADED.
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO -- JO LIST
LONG?
>> I THINK I HAVE A LOT OF --